it's going to make a joke question but
how many times have people asked you to
do like voicemails saying like lines or
not at all
a lot but I don't get sick of it I mean
I have the coolest catchphrase ever yes
I'm not gonna complain I want to know
what do you think fans are going to
think at the end of episode eight
what do I think they're gonna think well
I think they're going to be some people
who are like yeah and some people who
are like I hate this because there
always are that yeah
so you don't think fans are always happy
but you like to complain about things
rightfully so I can't win this question
we can move on um I like learning about
the behind the scenes of the show so
what do you think uh Mandalorian fans
would be surprised to learn about the
making of the Mandalorian oh golly well
it takes forever because there's so many
um I mean to make it look so cool like
it's astonishing to me to shoot it and
to see what it looks like when we're
shooting it and then to watch it and see
how incredible it is and I go oh my gosh
I didn't know I was on that location and
I wasn't it's because you know like like
in the first episode when we were
shooting
um on the beach with that strange crocod
Gator Turtle
whatever it was that came after us it
looked like we were in this like
beautiful mountain lake and I said I
really would like to go there but we
were on this back lot where they had
like built this artificial Pond and you
know dumped in some sand and it's
astonishing the things that they can do
um what do you actually
I'll have so many questions what do you
actually think is the hardest stuff for
you to pull off on set when it comes to
some of the stuff you're filming
hardest to pull off on set yeah maybe
because someone's like I was going to
make a joke that someone no yeah make a
joke no I was gonna make a joke about
people you know trying to mess you help
you mess up you know to break or
whatever well I messed myself up enough
just by like because the armor is always
very serious very stoic and so but I
also like you know can't really see much
and it used to be that I couldn't season
one my gloves were so big and John
called them my oven mitts and so I would
go to try to like pick up some of my
tools because I'm supposed to be a very
competent forger and welder and metal
worker and I couldn't grasp things
because the gloves were just too big and
bulky which is embarrassing when you're
trying to be competent at your job
um so that was a pretty easy way to make
people laugh unintentionally
um there have also been plenty of
moments when there's you know it's din
yarn in me and we're having a serious
moment we're talking and then being
close proximity and then we just Bonk
helmets and so immediately it's like
three stooges and there's uh I mean I
have so much fun though especially when
I'm when I'm doing scenes with with the
little green guy and it's his coverage
and uh and you know they're shooting
them and it's so important because we're
shooting grogu but Goku's a puppet we
know he's a puppet you're ruining the
illusion
and so I just I just have him like sing
songs and I'll just like pipe in lines
that he could be saying that he's not
really saying and and I'm not worried
about messing up a real actor because
there's a lot of kids watching this that
are really upset
on that note I'm just going to say
congrats I really can't wait to see
where the season's going like how it's
going to be happy I think you'll be
happy I think every will be happy
it's a great ending the season I love it